I was still like into the idea of using
my sexuality to for my benefit and
putting about putting you know value on
my sexuality and putting value on my
body and using it to my advantage so I
then talked to a friend
this was like several years like I don't
know a couple years ago talked to a
friend and she was like you should get a
sugar daddy and I was like oh my god
cuz you know a lot of my like webcam
clients wanted to meet me and I was so
freaked out by that idea I was like
there's no way I could like ever break
down this fourth wall yeah or like
there's no way I could ever have sex
with like one of these dudes that are
like giving me money for like you know
enjoying lurking yeah yeah so I was like
there's no way and Nick does it a lot it
seems like somebody that does Vince are
cool if you do it anyway I mean like
sometimes I even to this day like to go
on and like look at the girls and all
like load some money and like give them
tips and stuff because I think it's
super fun yeah um and so so then there
was that moment where you talk to
another girl she had a sugar daddy and
she said you've got it
yeah maybe tried this and I was like
okay but she was like don't do what I
did she's like I did really dangerous
things I would just like you know get on
a plane and fly she said actually like
flew to Jamaica once and like like
without really knowing that like the guy
was gonna be super safe or whatever
there was really no like screening
practices like what I do now but so I
did that and what I figured out was
sugar daddies are extremely cheap and
manipulative and like it's just I don't
know if you're you're listening and you
have a sugar daddy they're probably a
blacklisted Escort client because
they're just though they'll be really
flashy with their money and like I have
all of this stuff but they will be super
cheap about like giving you you know
more than its it was just I wasn't
getting what I do mean Jewish or what
are you talking about
just I was I had one for like my very
first one I had for like seven months
and he was just like you don't want to
be a you know I don't I don't really
want to
you know the H ook R word because I hate
that word but he's like you don't want
to do that the hooker yeah he's like you
you don't want to do that that's dirty
that's disgusting he was like but then
he was still paying you to do it he was
paying me I got away with like I mean he
was not an attractive human whatsoever
and he just had a shitty personality and
I got away with like out of seven months
I think I only slept with him like five
times so I was able to like get you know
but he wouldn't get me enough to for me
to like save and like save and you know
I still had like a vanilla like regular
drop at the same time too and do you
feel then so these so the sugar daddy
thing I have a friend that him that goes
on a lot of those sites in as dates with
those with the girls from sinking
arrangements yes all the time
right yeah all the time I mean literally
four nights a week and he it's kind of
you know I love the guy it's a little
gross sometimes the way he yeah it's
almost like shopping or something for
him in a way you know which is which
isn't bad I mean I think he did he kind
of just wants company you know right
right but it seems like for some people
that can get yeah it doesn't seem like
there's any benefit for the women
sometimes there's what it doesn't seem
there's very blurred boundaries and you
had like they're there's so many girls
on there that are in the end the guys
are like oh well I I can get this much
for two hundred right you know girls are
doing things for way less money than I
would do right at this point and they
were like I was like yeah I do sugar
baby stuff and I don't know I'm kind of
a little afraid to like go full into
professional escorting they're like oh
my god it's so much better like it's
good to have the boundaries the time
limits everything and I'm like yeah that
does sound like it would be like better
for me mentally because this like these
issues that I was having with the sugar
daddies with like with the no boundaries
in the manipulation and like just it was
all bad it was really dark it was a dark
period in my life um so because the men
have all the power
yes they do and I mean I feel so badly
for the girls that / I mean there's a
ton of them I feel so badly don't
participate on that so many and because
I think
this like sugar baby lifestyle is like
really like inflated on social media
horrified on Instagram yet I'm on this
yeah you never see any of the old dudes
in the background I see any you just
never realized what's really going on
and yeah that's impact but its impact
but there must be something empowering
about that but you're saying it sounds
like for you it turned more like in a
business um well no the guys are just
honestly those guys are just [__]
shitty they're just users they don't
they yeah they want to get as much as
they can for as little as possible buddy
that does it honestly you know that's
exactly how he is yeah they want that's
why they're and I think honestly a lot
of them are blacklisted clients because
you know escorts stick to their [__]
boundaries right we're like no I will
not see you for less than my rate sorry
move along don't go sugaring just
because you are you know seeing the
fantasy of it on Instagram like yeah you
have no I mean I especially nothing was
more shady than when I was sugaring like
an that [__] was shady as [__] there was
some there was not good things happening
that has not happened while I've been in
escort so do you feel like obviously
with sugaring it's a lot of guys they
get on these sites there's no exact
terms a lot of times I've never been
involved in this but I hear I hear about
it firsthand one of it all the time from
a friend of mine right and a friend who
I would never let date a sister of mine
or even let her be around him probably
for the weekend but also who I is still
a buddy and and I love him you know we
had a funny guy like you know I can
separate that for me as his friend but
um but yeah he gets on these things he
you know he tells he'll take them out to
somewhere nice they go to somewhere nice
and then there's never any like payment
or compensation a lot of them it seems
like feel like they need to have sex in
order to keep the guy around and then
that guy never calls them again yep look
that's my experience with sugaring I
went to nice dinners and stuff and then
it was like this like taboo to even talk
about like oh how much money am I gonna
get and like they would almost make you
feel bad for even at like it was so
there was just no clear boundaries
there was no right and that gives you
nothing as though it was just such an I
mean son I did get money I was able to
like you know have somewhat of a little
savings built up from that but it was so
it was very laborious it was I mean it
was a lot of work it was a lot of work
yeah and what type of girls get like
where's there a moment for girls where
they think about getting a sugaring
where they can they can what could they
do at a certain moment to do something
else and not get into any of it um not a
not it not get involved with any sex
work yeah nothing online nothing I mean
I don't know I guess sex work is the
same as any work like I mean minimum
wage retail I guess like I think that's
like I worked retail to like I think
that's like that's the the kind of pit
you fall into either retail or even like
serving in a restaurant or whatever or I
mean go to school I don't know like yeah
I guess [__] worked at a um hot topic
for a while dude actually got
electrocuted once at a hot topic I fell
into a box of [__] beavis and
butt-head lamps and I got electrocuted
well thanks for watching that video
right there that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe